So what we've seen is that
there's this belief, right?
So now it sounds very
familiar that Creole language
has emerged through
these abnormal breaks,
structural breaks
that, according
to many linguists-- perhaps,
most linguists-- put Creoles
outside the realm of
quote, "normal languages."
And I have to
insist on the quote
because I don't believe that.
I want to say it upfront.
I don't believe that
Creoles are to be
excluded from the realm
of normal languages.
And from your Mud
Card feedback, it's
clear that you
yourself are feeling
very unhappy with
this classification.
So what are we doing now?
We're doing something very--
which I hope is scientific.
We're looking at
the claims, what
do they imply for the
actual structures of Creoles
as I speak them, as
Karen's parents speak them,
as real living systems.
So what do these claims mean
for those real languages
that people actually
speak in their homes,
in their schools, et cetera?
So this is the basic question.
So are these, quote
unquote, "dicontinuities"
that we find in the
history of Creoles,
are the deeply
distinct from what you
find in the history of English?
And this is what we're
looking at the last time.
And then, once we have the
results of this comparison,
then we can ask, so
what does that mean
in terms of what we should
believe about Creole languages.
So this is just a summary of
what we discussed last week.
So what we saw in
that summary is
that both in its lexicon,
in its vocabulary,
but also in terms
of its syntax--
and we focused on one particular
aspect of English syntax
having to do with where
you pronounce the verb,
without the adverb.
And there's some examples where
English has a very different
order now than it had
in middle English,
like the 14th, 15th century.
Not only that, we also saw
that English, in a way,
has broken the morphology, the
conjugation of middle English.
So what we see in the
history of English
is a set of
comparative facts that
show that the history
of English, in a way,
is very much like the
history of Haitian Creole
as it emerged from French.
In fact, what we
saw is that, if you
look at the
vocabulary of English,
it's much more, quote
unquote, "macaronic."
It's a much more
mixed vocabulary
in terms of words coming
from French, from Latin,
from other languages as compared
to the vocabulary of Haitian
Creole, which is at
least 90% French.
So on one hand, you have a
Creole language with the, quote
unquote, "well-behaved"
vocabulary,
where most of the words
come from one language.
And on the other hand,
you have English,
which is supposed to be a
normal, genetic language
that nobody disrespects.
English is a world
language in a way.
It's a [INAUDIBLE] But yet,
English, in its vocabulary,
is much more macaronic,
much more misbehaving,
than, I think, words from all
over the world, so to speak.
So what we did conclude--
and we're going to
actually see more data that
will support this
conclusion-- is
that, with respect to the syntax
and the morphology of verbs
and also in terms
of its lexicon,
there is no key difference
between creolization
in the history of Haitian
Creole versus language change
as in the history of English.
In fact, if there's
any difference,
it would make English out
Creole Haitian Creole.
English would be
even more Creole
in a particular way
than Haitian Creole.
And now what I want to
show you very quickly
is that these facts come
up throughout the grammar
of English.
So here, we're going to look
at one other set of facts
having to do with where you
pronounce object pronouns.
So I'm going to give you some
examples from Haitian Creole.
So by now, you should--
Bouki and Boukinet
should be very familiar.
They are folk characters
in Haitian tales
that, when I was a
kid, I would listen to.
Bouki is supposed to be like
a not very smart character.
And then, there's Boukinet,
which is his wife.
So Bouki konnen Boukinet.
and then if you replace
Boukinet by pronoun,
you say Bouki konnen li.
Now what's striking
here is something
which is, as an English
speaker, you would accept
without hesitation, which is
that the object, whether it's
a name, like Boukinet, or
whether it's a pronoun,
like him or her or it,
it comes after the verb.
You see Bouki konnen
li, like in English, you
would say Bouki knows
him, or Bouki knows her,
or Bouki known it.
You cannot have the pronoun
come before the verb.
You cannot say Bouki li konnen.
Now some of you know French.
So if you know French,
you'll say, well, gosh no.
Here again, Creole has
broken the syntax of French.
Because in French, the
order into Bouki li konnen
is what you get in French.
You have this rule where if
the object is a pronoun, then
you have to move it to
the left of the verb.
OK, this is what we get now.
You say, Bouqui
connait Bouquinette.
And you say, Bouqi la connait.
So now the pronoun "la"
refers to Bouquinette.
And it better come
before the verb.
You cannot say,
Bouqui connait la.
So that's a very robust
contrast between Haitian Creole
and French--
whether you pronounce the
object when it's a pronoun.
OK, so this is our summary.
In the summary, you see
clearly where the differences
are in terms of not only
the object pronoun, but also
in terms of what we saw last
week in the last three rules
in terms of where you
pronounce the adverb, negation.
These are the final verb.
So Vfin is verb final.
In these two cases, what
you have here and there,
you have a reversal
of the order.
So in Creole, you
have verb, pronoun.
In French, you
have pronoun, verb.
In Creole, you
have adverb, verb.
In French, you
have verb, adverb.
And then, something
else we saw is
that in Creole, unlike
French, suffixes
are expressed as pre-verbal
items from last time.
If you look at this
particular pattern here,
which is like what we saw
earlier, where the object--
this is the case of
me saying, I eat rice.
So in Creole, you
say, Mwen mange dvi,
where you have rice
after the verb.
You should say, I'm eating rice.
You say Map manje dvi.
Do you remember that
theory about explication?
What's the claim, Nick?
NICK: It's just that Creole
languages are the lexicon
of the [INAUDIBLE] overlaid
onto the grammar of the--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: That's right.
That's right, very good.
So that's a very nice,
one-sentence summary
of this theory.
So basically, the Creole
grammar is a mix between, say,
in the case of Haiti, between
French and Gbe grammar.
So you take the
words from French.
And then the words are
imposed on the grammar
of an African language.
In the case of Haiti, it
would be the grammar of Gbe.
So now, one should ask, in the
case of this particular order
that we saw is different
from French, we could ask,
where does it come from?
Well, maybe it comes
from the Gbe languages.
Because, in fact, in Gbe,
you have this SV order.
You do subject, verb,
object, where the object
is pronounced after the verb.
Like here, you say, I eat rice.
This is how you say--
I won't try to pronounce
it, because it's a tone
language, very complicated.
So I don't know the tones.
But I have a colleague that I
wrote paper with, Enoch Abo.
And Enoch speaks Gbe language.
So these are data from Enoch.
I eat rice, very
much like here--
subject, verb, object order.
But yet, there is a twist.
And this is where we cannot
say that Creole grammar is
the explication of Gbe grammar.
Because, in fact,
like in French,
you do get OV order in Gbe.
So you get it here.
When you have an
aspectual marker,
meaning that you
go from saying, I
eat rice, to I'm eating
rice where you express
the progressive, the way
you express the progressive,
you have I and something
like the verb to be.
And you get rice eat.
And then you have this
other marker at the end.
So here, you can see
clearly that this pattern
in Haitian Creole is different,
both from French and from Gbe.
Because both French
and Gbe have OV order--
object verb order-- but Haitian
Creole doesn't have that.
So this is just a
quick data point
to actually show you that those
theories that either claim
that Haitian Creole is lexified
from some African language
and those theories that claim
that Haitian Creole is broken
French syntax to some degree,
they are both inaccurate.
So what are going
to do now, we're
going to actually look of
a case of language change.
And we're going to go
back to English where
you'll find the same pattern.
We have, at some point in
the history of English,
we also had OV order.
And then at a later point,
this OV order was lost.
And we can actually do it pretty
straightforward using data.
These are data
from older English.
So what you see here,
this is a sentence
in Old English
that would express
this idea of the Permians
told him many stories.
And what you have
to focus on here
is the fact that the pronoun,
him, is pronounced before told.
So many stories him
told the Permians.
And this is fine Old English.
So if you are living
in Old English time,
this is the way
you would say it.
And it was very productive.
So here, too, you see,
that he would give him
15 pounds in gold--
that he him gave.
You see where you have the
pronoun, him, before the verb.
Now that should
ring a bell when it
comes to the history
of Haitian Creole.
Because, again, in
French, pretty much
like in Old English, you
had a similar pattern.
If we take the same
examples in English,
and you say it in French,
we have a similar pattern,
where the object, him, is
pronounced before the verb,
to tell.
So you would say, quelles
histoires lui raconteront ils?
You see you have lui
before raconteront.
And then here, this is similar
examples from the Old English.
Il lui donna quinze
livres d'or, where lui--
the him pronoun-- is pronounced
before the verb, to give.
So what is that telling us?
It's telling us that,
in fact, pretty much
like what we showed before in
the history of the adverb, verb
pattern, that modern
English, like Haitian Creole,
has shown a drastic
change in word order.
You had before, adverb,
verb order arising
from verb, adverb order.
In this case, you have object,
verb order making place
for verb, object order.
So if one were to say
that Haitian Creole broke
the syntax of French,
then you would
have to also claim that
English broke the syntax of Old
English and modern English.
And then, you can see that
it doesn't make sense.
Why would one case
be "creolization"
that's supposed to be abnormal
change, and the other cases,
well, it's just language change?
In fact, what we
see is that, even
if you look at the history
of French in North America,
you find similar patterns.
So there are various
varieties of French
which are not called
Creole languages, which
are just called Missouri
French or Louisiana French.
And what you find in
these varieties of French
are similar patterns.
Again, in European French,
you would say, ils me verront.
They will see me.
Here, you will say, je
te mettrai tout en blanc.
This is Parisian
French, where you
have the object comes before
the verb in those two patterns.
Or you would say,
je l'enterrerai
dans les feuilles, where
you have the pronoun, le--
which is elided as l'--
coming before the verb.
Now I picked these examples
because I found instances
of these same patterns in Cajun
friends and Missouri French
where you have a
different order.
so here you see, you
say, il v'ont voir moi.
This is Cajun French.
What's striking here is that
the object pronoun, moi, is
pronounced after the verb--
il v'nont voir moi.
Actually, there isn't
much difference.
It's just that the verb,
the non-finite form, you
say, voir, which means to see.
It's not finite.
It doesn't take
agreement on it or tense.
The tense expressed, by the
way, the verb that comes before.
It's like, I will see
you, or I will see me,
or they will see me.
You get the marker before the
verb to express the future.
And then, you get the
object after the verb.
And the same is true here.
J'vas mettre tou** tout en blanc.
Again, the key form here is
the object pronoun, tou**,
which comes after mettre, which
is not like European French.
It's very unlike
European French.
And here as well--
m'as enterrer elle
dans les feuilles.
Again, elle is the pronoun.
It comes after the verb.
So in all three
of these patterns,
you'll find something which
is very Creole-like, right?
Like in Louisiana,
there is a Creole.
But this is not the Creole.
This is French.
This is Cajun French.
This is Missouri French
in the last two examples.
So what does that mean?
It means that Cajun and Missouri
French, like Haitian Creole,
they exhibit the same
sort of patterns.
Where European French
has object, verb order,
those French varieties
have the reverse pattern.
The conclusion for now
is that, here too, we
have the clear appearance
of Creole-like patterns
in those varieties which
are not called Creoles.
So it is pretty much
the same argument
as before that you find those
linguistic types of changes
in non-Creole languages.
So then, what's the
value of positing
that you have particular changes
that are specifically Creole,
like creolization?